my parents came from Pakistan they were
Pakistani migrants in Britain but we
being born and raised there had to kind
of grapple with these questions of what
it meant to be a Muslim born in the west
so when we were facing a lot of that
violent racism
and I'm talking machete attacks Hammer
attacks when I say violent it was brutal
um I witnessed my first murder at 17th
uh stabbing to death who was doing the
attacking
British so this was a group of neo-nazis
they affiliated with combat 18 uh which
is a um if it was formed as a
paramilitary organization in Northern
Ireland by serving soldiers who were
fighting the Irish republicanism there
and they became Uber nationalist in that
sense and uh 18 stands for the order of
the letters in the alphabet of Adolf
Hitler's initials so a being one and H
being X